all right so welcome to session 15 of
classic middle class uh scott is here
with me and he's actually going to be
talking a lot not just about lyrical
content but about gear and tech and
approaches in music because the topic
that we have this time
is a reprisal of a previous topic where
we were talking about metal covers and
what makes them
metal and we we've been kicking this
around since that session and we thought
that and this is kind of an interesting
hypothesis that i would i'd love to hear
what other people have to say about this
if we want to see by contrast you know a
metal song and then the original
that the metal song is covering maybe we
would do better to not focus on certain
genres that are kind of low-hanging
fruits where it's it's what we call
metal adjacent like blues or
hard rock or punk or a even aor uh stuff
and maybe we should look instead at
metal covers of pop songs or jazz or
r b things that are not as close to
metal and then the you know well what
makes this metal what makes this
successful metal
might come out a little bit more clearly
and so we've got a number of uh
bands and and songs that we talked about
last time but we've got a whole bunch of
new ones as well and i think we're going
to do a deeper dive on on some of these
uh for example saxon's
cover of christopher cross's ride like
the wind they also did a cover of toto
hold the line interestingly enough as
well
so what are you going to say scott well
you know hold the line is a pretty heavy
tune
um yeah
so do you think we do you think that one
doesn't fit into the matrix of what
we're looking at here is that is it too
hard rocky or
well here's what's interesting
steve lucas of the guitarist was one of
the you know of toto was one of the most
recorded guitar players through the 80s
and 90s as a session player
everybody that's owned albums he's on
him and like you know whether it's cher
michael bolton chicago
he was but
he's actually you know
as versatile a musician as he is
he's like you know
a shredder he's uh a heavy player and um
so but with the total stuff especially
the total stuff up until the 90s was
very uh
i don't know they they called them in
journey early alr
yeah so but hold the line makes sense to
me um
as you know like i've even played in
i've toured with um
uh r b bands that like the groove of
that so we would play into the set but
i've also been in heavy bands in the
past that want to cover it because
it's that riff is so heavy yeah there's
there's something there that's not yet
metal but is
easily
turned into metal
right that's right
yeah
now mark asks an interesting question
where would you situate western
classical music stuff like bach and
beethoven i mean as far as like the
purposes of this we're talking about
metal bands covering that and and i
think they're i mean you can talk about
a few metal covers of classical
music where they take classical music as
it is instrumentalize it in a different
way and make it heavy but it's more
often that there's um an incorporation
into the song so think about accepts
metal heart right
where um
it's for a lease that they take a little
section off and put it in there
uh it's not it's not the whole song but
it's it's a portion
um and you know sabotage's hollow the
mountain king
comes to mind as well
um the song off of that that titled
album
um
you know and we could talk about like
the neoclassical
metal people
you know ingva malmsteen comes to mind
as as sort of
not not the only originator of it but
like a very important girly figure and
here's where scott would would i don't
listen much to ingva malmsteen and i
know that you've listened a lot more to
him um i mean how much
how many we wouldn't talk about a cover
song we would talk about taking a a line
or a passage from
a classical piece and incorporating it
right well
um
uh well blackboard used to play um all
right
oh gosh why am i forgetting he actually
played i mean you know he played it on
you know electric guitar which one did
they play but invade used to do
beethoven's fifth in his
he'd concerts some arrangement of
beethoven's fifth um and and i think for
him who's he was trying to prove how
legitimate he was but you know he's not
a legitimate classical musician by any
stretch but um
i think european metal
um
they definitely you're right there's a
lot of quoting going on but there has
been like um
you know metal treatments of
a lot of is bach-esque
you know if you listen to the phrases
there's
clearly
stealing phrases block pieces i think
that's that's right and why do you think
that is given like the
you know broad spectrum of other
um
you know musicians or the composers that
they they could pick why is bach so
attractive to them
well
i mean i can say for myself and it's
kind of widely regarded if you listen to
bach
we all say one thing it's perfect music
it's it's one of some of the most genius
music i think that that was ever written
and you know
paganini was another one for ingva and
paganini was you know
very much like ingva was you know
paganini was a you know a very kind of
ornate figure okay and um he pushed the
you know
what the violin can do and his pieces
were very very difficult so i think
there was some where you know invade had
this talent and he would work on these
pieces with his electric guitar and
you know i think he was pretty much
interested in it but he did him and
blackmore kind of brought this to the
forefront as a new genre but um
and this is my own opinion that i'm
putting here not as a fact but um i
think there's a kind of a badge of honor
it's like i like the real guys you know
it's kind of like you know
uh the people that are like well i like
you know i like uh
i like pop music like the kiss fm stuff
but you know hey with metal it's got to
be sabbath you know and and it's like
their bag of honor to like be right
you know some of the best stuff so um
that was a really good question actually
because um
european metal uh in the 70s and 80s you
know even michael shanker you know he
would hear um
you would hear kind of some quotes
yeah um but like you know uh
invade did
you know cover something
like uh on acoustic guitar or something
that was a piece like whether it was
like a bit of a bach or something i mean
randy rhodes comes to mind as somebody
who's doing
stuff like that as well um and sometimes
it's getting into his his actual like
recorded compositions and sometimes it's
like well this is the stuff he does on
the side for for fun right it's
interesting you said that because um
randy was just starting to look at
classical guitar and he was studying leo
brauer pieces the um
the composer okay and diary of a madman
is literally
you know one of the uh i don't remember
the the brower piece but it's literally
leo brower i'm tired of mad man you
think about d
no no diary of a madman the song you
know the okay yeah
and that's like a leo brower kind of
thing
he was working on that and
he clearly brought that to the table as
a
brower-esque thing but i only recognize
it because i know leo brauer's work yeah
so what we've got in a lot of cases is
incorporation of things that are
classical but not complete covers mark
has another one that's an interesting
suggestion too what about hendrix's
cover of the star spangled banner very
iconic piece right and
is it metal um i mean it's arguably
proto metal as hendricks's work in
general is
it would be you know one of the greatest
what-ifs
of heavy metal history is what if jimi
hendrix hadn't died in 1970 what would
his contribution
have been like as you know bands like
black sabbath uriah heap deep purple ufo
all of these were bursting on the scene
you know um
i don't know i mean
hendrix's version is is definitely a
cover right it's an instrumental cover
it's it's it's doing some very
innovative stuff you know the rockets
red glare is trying to use the guitar to
um
what would be the the
musical equivalent of otamatopaia where
you know a word
sounds like the thing he's using a
guitar to to try to um
present us with a soundscape
right well that's the thing so the
version of that
it's a great one to bring up because
jimi hendrix was of course one of the
greatest innovators ever but the thing
about jimi hendrix is nobody can really
copy him he was a sonic
know if you ever heard machine gun from
the band of gypsies
we call it the control of feedback and
what feedback is is if i have my
electric guitar and i have a marshall
cranked up
and you get in that one spot where
there's a there's a
loop where you start hearing that
yeah yeah
and um if you listen to the
star-spangled banner
he'll he'll hit that sweet spot where
he'll get it and he'll his intonation is
exactly what he wants when he
puts the bar down um
and you know people just say well he's
just making a bunch of noise
no i mean that he that was like uh
and that and that's the thing that blew
everybody away you know we always called
him an alien
um not that i was on the planet with him
but you know we refer to him as an alien
i mean yeah yeah and um because
i you know i i often still listen to
hendrix through my monitors very loud
and he doesn't have a shrill sound and
it's just so the star-spangled banner
was really interesting and
if anybody saw him on the dick cavett
show um you should look it up because
he gets asked that question dick cavett
says well why are you
playing the star-spangled banner you
know and um
he said i don't know you know they made
me sing it in school and you know i
thought
you know and um and then he said well
you know and he says to the audience
kind of jokingly like kevin you know
before you send your hate mail to him um
this you know this guy was a paratrooper
in the army or whatever because jimi
hendrix served in the military
and
jimi hendrix says what do you mean
um hate mail
he goes well when you do something
unorthodox with a piece like that so
kind of sacred you're going to bring
uh you're going to bring you know anger
and jimi hendrix kind of looked off and
says
that wasn't unorthodox i thought it was
beautiful and it was just
it was just uh you know i don't mean to
get off into tangier but that's a really
insightful question yeah well i will i
will bring up attention to this and a
bit of a rant um you know when when you
hear the star-spangled banner song
as you so often do before
ball games or stuff like that i myself
can't stand how people
feel like they have to embellish upon it
in a way that makes it their own but
isn't making it their own they're just
like every other person inserting a
whole bunch of extra notes and
flourishes and stuff like that
and
you know compare that to jimi hendrix's
own version of it which is raw and
straightforward confident
i'm sure plenty of practice went into it
but it's it's very different than the
generic almost
you know show offy saccharin
style of of things i you know when when
we're watching these um you know like a
football game or something like that we
often just mute it because i don't i you
know my wife is a bit more forgiving
towards that
i don't want to hear it
you hit something great great here greg
um uh you you mentioned something about
jimi hendrix that you know what he was
playing um
fit with the lyrics
right yeah yeah and
we heard with jimi hendrix was um
communication i have a distinction with
artists so that he's communicating
however i agree with you about the
people that sing it because they're
demonstrating
you know and what they do at ball games
is when we hit the rock it's red glare
that's when the pyrotechnics go up okay
so that and that's something separate
from the singing right it's something
that the singer can count on basically
as like a prop has nothing to do with
them right right other than they're
giving the cue hey time to shoot the
rockets up so
not that i'm against like pyrotechnics
at all i mean when i was a kid i
actually wanted to be a fireworks maker
believe it or not oh that's pretty cool
i didn't know that
yeah didn't didn't happen even though
there was a fireworks factory
literally just down the road
from
where i grew up the the bartolotta uh
fireworks factory and i if i was serious
about it i suppose i could have gotten
in there with them we should come back
to to our our main topic
so so we're going to look at some some
covers
um and you know so we're not going to
look at these
metal adjacent genres
um you know for example judas priest
better by you better than me spooky
tooth is arguably a hard rock band so we
will look at diamonds and rust but we're
not going to look at
better than you better than me even
though it's an awesome metal cover we're
not going to look at punk to metal like
mega death's anarchy in the uk
which i i'd say is about as good as the
song it's covering but i don't think
either of them are particularly great um
we're not going to be looking much at
blues
we talked last time about aerosmith's
train kept a rolling as as kind of a
definitive metal version probably better
than motorhead's
version or other ones so we're gonna be
looking at you know genres like r b or
softer rock you know easy listening
perhaps right pop jazz stuff like that
and there was a uh uh funny quote that i
wanted to start us with it's a little
bit of a take on hey jude i found it on
femme metal rocks
so it goes hey jude don't make it bad
take a pop song and make it better
remember to add some riffs in a solo
then you can start to make it metal now
[Laughter]
is that all it takes to make something a
metal song
it's it's a what we would call
a
perhaps necessary but it's not a
sufficient condition right
i mean songs already have riffs
you could add you could you could do
something with the riff adding a solo
okay that that might contribute to it
but there's a lot more that goes into
making
something metal
and you know i was going to talk first
about
ethos
but maybe this would be a good place to
switch the order a bit and have scott
talk a bit about on the one hand
gear and tech and on the other hand the
let's call them the sonic aspects what
what contributes to something
really being a
metal song
so
there's a lot of nuance so take
um i don't know if everybody's heard um
ozzy's cover of staying alive
and um
now that sounds funny but like uh and of
course
if i remember correct it starts off with
everybody get on the disco train instead
of the crazy train right
and so it's kind of seems
tongue-in-cheek at first but um
i'm pretty sure he did that with weasel
zappa
okay that was a that was weasel's zap on
guitar and if you listen everything's
identical but why is it driving like a
metal tune it's the drumming
that's it so the drumming um in the
the bg's version there's kind of more of
like a double time on the hi-hat like
you know
like it's a little funkier
here
um i don't know who the drummer on this
track was but they were rock solid the
you know there was no kind of um behind
there was no kind of like uh
accenting on on the drums it was here's
the downbeat and if you listen to the
hi-hat specifically
uh the two next to each other
in aussies version the the the um
drummer's playing half time on
half time means if it's going da da da
da da da da da da da da da da half time
love you
right yeah yeah so and and what that
does is that allows
room of the stay alive riff which weasel
plays note for note from the original
all of a sudden
that allows that riff to settle
and sound heavier than it
did at the previous one because it was
kind of like a funk lick
and so here's an example of
everything was the same except the drums
and um
you know rhythmic subdivision um
i think we all know
rhythmic subdivision is essential to how
a groove lays or how it's presented and
a lot of people don't think about the
bass or the drums um
and the bass sound of course is going to
be a lot brighter on the bg's version
it's going to be a lot more mid-range
here on the aussie version if you listen
to the tone it's it's a little more it's
it's heavier fuller in the lower end
right yeah right there's more in the
lower end and it's like um
it's
instead of focusing on the mid-range
which a lot of funk
bass players are
you know disco or whatever um so the
rhythm section not the guitar or the
vocals the guitar and the vocals are the
same
um so the rhythm section made slight
adjustments and it became heavy
so um that's that's very interesting
because i think a lot of people
would automatically assume that what you
need to do in order to make something
metal is primarily about the guitars you
turn the distortion up you
add in some more low end you know
make the solos
much
you know
less sort of lyrical and more
blazing or
something along those lines and now
you've got a metal sign
a good example of that uh sorry to cut
you off but we'll go ahead
um tanks chain of fools yeah yeah this
is one of my favorites yeah
it's and it's a great cover and here's
the thing
um
what you said is true about this
um
the original
um the original guitarist was cornell
dupree it was on every atlantic record
all aretha's and he's got this riff um
if i may
sure so uh we get a treat this time
kind of like understated
so but what what i don't i don't know if
i have the right key
um but tank
[Music]
with heavy distortion it's the same riff
but it's power cords and it's full so
they keep the guitar hook the guitar
yeah yeah it's very subtle on the aretha
version but it's not subtle and um they
actually bring that subtle cornell to
pre-part out in your face
and um they recognize they kept i think
what was important to the tune and then
um
and you know
in that context
the lyrics sounded kind of metal like in
the sense of oh you know
yeah you know they really sold me on it
they really sold me on the lyrics in a
different way and i think that's a
that's a cover gone right
you know
and so what you're saying is true it's
like in that case it was like let's keep
that riff because it's important
although it's subtle but let's really
bring it out and make it heavy and um
it's not a simple formula but um
uh you know but they i think they did a
really good job with that one well this
is this is an interesting feature
so if you think about um some of the
genres that we're talking about they
might be less guitar forward you could
say i mean you think about a metal band
the guitarists are in the front
you know they're oftentimes the uh the
showmen
um there are some exceptions right lemmy
bassist out there in front and
motorhead is whoever's let me get
playing with him while he's still alive
um but
on steve harris you know arguably as
well right um
i agree he he dominates the stage no
matter where he is even today
as old as as old as he is um
but um
a lot of the you know so r b
um pop you know even soft rock you could
say the bass really plays an important
role
quite often that the guitar is it's
occupying a space that the guitar is not
occupying whereas with metal guitar is
always in in the mix unless you're doing
a bass solo or unless it's like a base
lead-in or something like that
and
so some genres i i think r b good
there's so much great basis stuff
happening
in
especially in motown
that
somebody could take a lot of those songs
and transform them
quite easily into metal songs maybe the
lyrical content might be tricky
depending on the song
but the
you know the rhythm section stuff is
right there
i agree it's like you know um first one
that comes to mind that would not work
is i'm a soul man
um
um but you know what about some of sam
cooke's stuff i mean sam cook's one of
my favorite singers of all time um
and
you know um
i don't know what one specifically but
like you know um
when we
need the artist to talk about heartbreak
you know if they're gonna that's a theme
in you know love gone wrong yeah
that's kind of a crossover i mean into a
lot of genres and i think if the singer
can sell
the sentiment of the lyrics and they
have to be able to do that like we're
talking about the star spangled banner
yeah you're not buying it from these
people because they're they're they're
being
not genuine
um
when um
so like you know when i heard
tanks version i said you know i'm like
this this is well you know to go back to
tank right lyrically one of their
biggest hits is um called
wmla wasting my life away
and it's a song that i myself you know
cover playing it you know on the banjo
and and singing it um it can and it
works moving it from from structure to
structure because it's a very sappy
romantic song you know
it's uh the the chorus that plays three
times is uh
being it's about being in the rain uh at
two in the morning three in the morning
you know it's about heartbreak and
all sorts of things along those lines
and it's you know if you were just to
read it by itself the lyrics you would
be like this is not a metal song
but with the right
bass it you know algae ward singing and
and playing bass um the right drummer
and then you know the right uh in that
case two guitarists
they can sell it you know i mean they
also have songs like uh about falling in
love with a storm trooper they're very
oriented towards armor
and war
and things like that
um but they they also have a a great
song that
is heart-rending about um and it's a
later song
about um a child's life being lost
falling through
the ice and
the grief of the parents struggling with
that you know so a lot of a lot of it
really depends on how it's it's played
mark points something out kind of
interesting and i'd like to hear from
you on this scott because you watch a
lot more
musical stuff on youtube and i know that
you have some very strong feelings about
some of this a lot of metal covers on
youtube are like what we were talking
about metal means distorted guitar and
growling no
nuas
um
so
covers on youtube
um there's lots of people putting them
out there some of them are quite cool
where that's like the same person
playing all the different instruments
and it's like a split screen and you can
see them doing that
quite a few of them are pretty
uh mediocre right
yeah um
the thing about covers and
i see this with a lot of my students
they'll do a cover of something that's
big
okay
big at the time you mean like it's it's
likely to be forgotten down the line or
no big meaning it's good
uh it's being searched heavily so like a
cheap shot would be if you and i said
let's do a cover of war pigs yeah and so
every time somebody puts in war pigs
sabbath will come up with so will we
and so um
one of them
this isn't everybody's but one of the
inspirations or one of the things that
may inspire people to put covers on
there is they think they're going to get
attention out of it they're going to get
follows they're going to get like cl
like clicks they're going to get um and
and that's why you're seeing a lot of
mediocre because it's not people like
sitting down as a band going let's work
this out let's work this section out
it's just kind of let's throw this
together
you know it's already a great tune and
just the fact that you know everybody
searches for stairway to heaven or
something right yeah yeah so um
uh that's why sometimes i'll look for an
obscure tune
and uh usually obscure tunes come from
europe like um
one time i was looking for uh covers of
uh kiss's reason to live and there's a
lot of them from uh
like uh sweden
okay swedish bands and then the just uh
female singers because that's you know
he was singing really high in that
and um
and you know a lot of these people don't
speak english but like kind of sing the
words and um like close mind back of the
day
that's true yeah
exactly so um
i think uh
i i don't know if it's so much i guess
what i'm saying is
i don't think the covers are so much a
tribute when people
uh
kind of get together and go let's cover
this we'll get recognized we'll get more
likes we'll get more followers yeah
influencers and um
and it's the old thing that we used to
do in clubs when we were younger and i
never agreed with this where it's like
well you know what you got to do is you
go to the cover clubs and you sneak some
of your originals in well the drinking
crowd doesn't want to hear your
originals ever yeah yeah demographic
and um so it's kind of like the same
thing um i followed this one girl that
did all these great aor tunes she's
russian but then at the end she's like
please listen to my music and i never
did because
i was the i was there for the the hits
yeah you know and and that goes kind of
way back you know one of the bands we're
going to be talking about that did lots
and lots of covers on their actual
albums is van halen
and that's in part because they were a
cover band and they did covers
remarkably well um they had a massive
catalog and that's that's part of what
put them on the scene and there was kind
of a struggle because some clubs
that they were you know
earning money from and getting into
would not let them play original stuff
and other clubs would so
um
you know you can you can ask what's the
motive behind doing a cover is it to try
just to attract attention like scott was
talking about a moment ago
you know nowadays we do seo search
engine optimization and you can like do
a google
search and find you know which song uh
titles are getting the most hits and
then you could be very savvy that way
but that doesn't guarantee that your
cover is actually going to be
decent and it could be a metal cover
i think maybe we have to distinguish
here
doing a metal cover and doing a good
metal cover because there are a lot of
terrible metal covers
out there
mark brings up another thing too about
pop culture mash-ups metal covers of
non-metal songs is quirky enough to
catch attention from a mainstream
perspective yeah i think you know and i
think that's the case today
in a way that it wasn't
back when when metal was less mainstream
and more
not necessarily an underground but an
outsider kind of genre like when scott
and i were growing up you know if you
could actually get beaten up for wearing
you know a jacket full of patches on it
if the jocks caught you right and you
would not be hearing
yeah you would not be hearing heavy
metal songs being played as the filler
music at sporting events like they are
today i mean you watch the nfl and like
crazy train comes on and every time that
happens i'm thinking to myself god this
is weird because back in the day all the
people in charge of that hated us
yeah that's a good point you know that's
a good sociological perspective
yeah that's a whole other thing we won't
get into but um that is true um you know
the the music that happened you know if
you went to your football game even like
your high school football game you know
you wasn't gonna be the band playing
black sabbath
as it is today you got souza marches
exactly yeah yeah well and you know i
remember when i was in band and i was
only in it for uh freshman year because
i hated it um and we had like a we we
played some elo stuff
um oh cool because really yeah a bassist
came in and you know we were supposed to
do that but that was like our treat for
like a day and then we went back to all
the old stuff you know
yeah i played clarinet and i quit doing
it because i was like
you know i'm into this other kind of
music and you know obviously i i i could
have like learned how to you know if i'd
if i'd known about klezmer or something
like that and the possible crossovers
maybe i would suck with it but i was
like i don't want to play this crap you
know i want to i want to like learn some
other things that that are closer to the
music that i actually listen to so
yeah
yeah i mean so this is a good segue into
talking about um ethos and and you know
lyrical content and so what you know if
we're asking this question what makes a
song metal we've talked about some of
the sonic elements
um
just coming from a metal band doesn't
necessarily make it metal because a
metal band could have
something that's
arguably non-metal think about judas
priests um before the dawn yeah i don't
know i don't think that's a metal song
it's a beautiful song
yeah but i don't think it's it's
arguably metal um and as we mentioned
some non-metal songs are like almost
ready made for metal but something has
to bring this out it can't just be oh
i'm gonna turn up the amps and turn up
the distortion
and uh there has to be some exploitation
of the musical capacity something almost
like in chemistry where you catalyze
something that's there in solution and
maybe some songs don't have that and
other songs
do
and i do want to point out one i you
know i said we weren't going to talk
about hard rock but there is one hard
rock song that is seemingly
irresistible to metal bands to cover
and i've heard very very few good covers
of it that do justice to the original
and that is steppenwolf's born to be
wild you know
even bands that i really really like
like raven i don't want to hear them do
born to be wild you know or blow oyster
cult i mean that was on two of their
live albums
i mean they could have put one of their
own songs on why are they putting covers
on
the height of their career of their
lives
and why that particular cover why i mean
again here's where i could you know ask
you as a musician why do you think that
one is so
so attractive i mean there are dozens of
metal covers of that song uh because
we have to remember that
you know um
we have a uh
our growing up through high school we
had the music that was current and i
think for a lot of the metal bands
steppenwolf was one of the like the
probably cooler bands right okay they
were in high school yeah and so
that before you know they
made things heavier they would get
psyched up by hearing born to be wild
and maybe that never changed you know um
and of course you know the the sentiment
of it you know born to be wild is pretty
metal yeah you know but it's got the
word heavy metal thunder in it yeah
exactly
you're right heavy metal thunder um i
think you know um
some so some of sometimes i forget that
when i say why would they cover that
well they had those records when they
were coming up before they were playing
before they were in a band and
stuff that
you know because they're made a career
out of music
i have to imagine that music moved them
through their
childhood and and high school years and
you know they probably had the posters
on their wall too or or cut out from a
magazine and
you know it's funny you ask even metal
players you know that are
you know you're a little older they're
like yep the beatles and ed sullivan 64.
that's why i'm here and i love the
beatles you know and um
and you know when you're like you you're
just such a metal head or whatever and
you're like you know you're like you
know nope the beatles and of course you
know
uh this is interesting because you might
say that at least with classic metal
maybe not so much with like the genre
stuff from the 90s onward
it's in part the openness to other um
genres of music
that allows the ferment to happen
that
takes them you know if
i mean and it's different in the 80s
right if you look at um
what bands would say their influences
were the bands that were coming up in
the 80s they would say well you know i
listen to black sabbath and iron maiden
and judas priest and they'd name all
these
these uh uh now classic metal bands from
this you know the 70s and early 80s off
um this is actually a good place to
bring up something that i i found uh
blackie lawless saying in an interview
he was he was asked i was wondering what
kind of musical environment you grew up
in as you've done some cover songs on
your albums out of the most popular 70s
rock bands like jefferson airplane
somebody to love the who the real me and
forever free and elton john saturday
nights all right for fighting
you know wasp covering an elton john's
song is kind of an unusual thing and so
he's he blackie lawless says
my mother was a big fan of little
richards elvis presley chuck berry and
all that stuff i've always had that
music in my house and i've got a sister
who's like eight years older than me
who's a big beatles fan so you know i
had elvis presley in one room and the
beatles in another going at the same
time
i've always had that kind of music
around me when i was around 10 years old
i heard born to be wild for the first
time and that changed me you know so i
always had music around me and i was
exposed to it so i had a big jump on
everyone else that was my age when it
came to music by the time i was 15 black
sabbath had already been out for maybe
three four years and i remember them
being 15 guys telling me they were
hearing black sabbath when i was you
know when i was young for them three
years ago when i knew about them very
early so it's interesting that that
remark because on the one hand you've
got the pre-metal rock influenced stuff
a pretty heady brew right there and then
he's already exposed to
black sabbath long before his classmates
are as well and he as a you know musical
guy he's thinking about this this sort
of stuff
um
so i think there's
you know this is sort of what you're
talking about there right these these
musicians who
um
you look back and kind and it's kind of
unusual things like you know you asked
steve harris well who are you listening
to well um ufo
and i you know and i really liked uh uh
this guy uh pete way and then you know
yes and all this stuff that's not metal
at all i mean ufo is is is arguably
metal a good bit of the time um
and you know these things play a an
important role so it would it would
argue why you might want to cover things
like why it could make sense for a very
heavy band like wasp to cover
um and also a very
um
you know from its early on a very almost
hyper masculine band like wasp
to cover somebody like elton john
right yeah oh that's it yeah that's
interesting um well you know there's the
appearance reality factor i mean when we
grew up there was no twitter we didn't
know what yeah cars were doing
everything we didn't know their
political opinions everything was in our
imaginations and in the magazines we
were reading or if we're lucky something
like that part of the world that they
created so you know you have it on the
wall and like i remember even uh being
in a show and you know the pa music is
playing i'm like i'm wondering what
they're doing backstage are they even in
the building yet you know and we'd have
to like fill in what was missing
and
i think you know uh they'd be these
bigger than life people and of course
the interviews we read were probably
very uh you know the record label would
say you can't cannot ask this you can't
ask this and this is before you know
somebody had access to twitter and go
i'm having cereal right now i'm gonna go
do to the gym and he'd be like
don't go to the gym you know like that's
not cool that's not metal and i think
you know um to a degree
we just figured that they you know uh
i just uh not just a little off topic
even um jeff scott soto who sang with
ingvate just posted a picture of him and
jeff tate
um in seattle in 1985 when he was
singing with yngwie and you know um
queens reich was playing and i'm like
see now at the time i would never know
these guys hung out i thought they were
all rivals i thought they were all like
you know
gangs kind of thing you know and now
that stuff's coming out it's like oh man
we've known each other for years and
isn't this great it's like you know um
the way that it was shown to us was
what we needed to know which was
exciting you know
they created a world and we wanted to
get the merch we wanted to be close to
whatever that was and that's why it's so
odd to hear blackie lawless say the
beatles or elvis presley like oh you
even know who those people are you know
yeah in a way it kind of like dates him
further back right um
but
he is he is a pretty old guy and
you know we often um
it's almost as if we'd forget when we
were teenagers that this was not music
that was being made by teenagers for the
most part there were a few a few
exceptions like rock goddess you know
the uh the drummer was like 15 when
their first album came out and the the
oldest one was uh uh like 18 i think uh
but for the most part these were these
were people who were in their 20s or 30s
and were you know working hard and
probably you know like as you've pointed
out with like kiss had a routine down
they weren't partying backstage they
were like you know getting hydrated
well that's that's the big shocker to us
right yeah who could forget this cold
gin rant
you know but
me my friends used to do that rant daily
in the hallways you know we met some
people backstage that like vodka and
orange juice you know and they're like
we like cold gin and it's like but it
turns out they don't drink
yeah yeah
so you know the other thing that we were
going to talk about in terms of ethos
and i think we've already mentioned this
a little bit
um you know you can do a metal cover
where it's
a really great transformative you know
this becomes your thing like we're going
to talk about saxons ride like the wind
or
a few other ones
and you can also do mediocre covers
where it just doesn't really work that
well but then you can do covers where
it's almost sneering
it's sarcastic it's ironic it's like you
know and i think this happens a lot more
in punk and an alternative stuff than it
does in metal now that i if i bring it
to mind
where you take something and you're like
look at these jerks we're going to take
their song and we're going to mess it up
you know
or a famous one my brother was at a show
um
i i forget the band it's a famous punk
band okay and they came out
and they open with surfing bird
right you know like the old
was it 50s you know yeah bird bird is a
word
so but the the trick is they didn't stop
so every time it broke down
he'd come back in and he did it until
the crowd left
it like they didn't stop it was like 45
minutes of surfing bird they didn't do
anything so i mean like you know that's
like that's almost like andy kaufman
performance art
yeah
yeah
i mean not to say that you know
comedy isn't compatible with with metal
obviously right but um
well that's
paid for tickets yeah you know and and
sometimes i think the song
could become
a parody without the band intending to
do it that way so one that i have in
mind was one that we were gonna talk
about
um ugly kid joe a metal band from like
the late 80s their their version of cats
in the cradle um it's you know
definitely a metal song
i think they just kind of messed the
song up it doesn't convey it it
certainly is metal but it doesn't convey
much of
the ethos successfully of the original
song
now mark brings up um as a snarky cover
megadeth's cover of these boots were
made for walking which is another song
that we were gonna
talk about um
it's snarky it's snarky towards the
person it's talking to in the song
it's not snarky towards the artist
and i think that's an important
distinction that's right yeah so it's
not saying nancy sinatra look at this
this floozy you know who would she have
to sing about boots or something like
that but it is definitely and you know
there's other magnets
that are snarky in a similar way think
about peace cells but who's buying you
know um i you know you say i'm not kind
i'm not your kind right
um they they're pretty good at that that
sort of thing
i think it's a it's actually a great
metal cover and i think they did take it
and make it their own and when you when
you read dave mustaine's recent
autobiography
oh so
mark says i thought it was mustang
taking a poke at boomers
i don't think it was it was it was that
i mean
the gen x you know versus boomer thing
at the time that that that's coming out
wasn't quite uh
so pronounced as it was in the 90s you
know no
um dave mustaine would be on the
the
very early end i think of gen x that's
right
um
he'd actually be i think at the cusp of
boomers and and generally
it's more like hey
this is a song
i kind of think a lot of early megadeth
stuff
has two primary targets
um
the
girls or guys that dave mustaine doesn't
like because he's writing almost all the
lyrics
and metallica who's kicked him out
that's who you met at the beginning
the guys you know he doesn't like that
would be metallic there were other guys
he didn't like too you know it wasn't
just metallica but he really did have he
carried a
real chip on his shoulder about them for
a very long time and i i think rightly
so i mean they they did he he was a
drunk they were drunks
the way in which this is a total
tangent rant the way in which they fired
him was
pretty crappy um they they behaved in
kind of a cowardly way i would say
i mean it's interesting to think about
what metallica could have been
with dave mustaine remaining with them
and cliff burton you know
being there as well
if cliff burton hadn't died um but you
know they just couldn't keep it together
personality-wise so
but i mean it's a good um
it's a good example of the sort of thing
we're talking about because the nancy
sinatra song is nowhere near metal right
no gosh no it's
yeah i mean
so
let's let's take that one what happens
to that song scott that actually makes
it metal the lyrics don't change well
they do change a little bit um he he has
some things that he adds to it you know
about sex and stuff like that but
what music
and along with the lyrics it's kind of
like um
i i wanted to point out too the you know
like uh paul stanley had to switch the
gender of um and then she kissed me
right yeah yeah
so um
you know and it's so funny because we
were talking about that one and i knew
which tune you meant
right but you know then he kissed me
um
yeah i mean
uh we already talked about um
the rhythm section being very key to the
groove so um
if you take a song in in uh
i've said this before but i think it's
important to reiterate um if we take
just the lyrics and the chord
progression
and and you see maybe on a staff here
are the chords that go above and here's
the melody line and here are the words
so we could take a look at it and go
well
the words could
you know are open to be a country song
or a pop song or a actually this would
work in metal and actually just like but
then um this is the production side that
um
so uh i was going to get to so let's say
that somebody brings you and i just the
lyrics the melody and the chords and we
have nothing else to go by there's no
demo there's no
genre involved
and you say to me well we let's make
this metal now we have nothing
we have nothing um to go by so like when
they when he does uh the nancy sinatra
well there was something to depart from
but if yeah yeah if we take the the boil
it down to
and take style out of it
then it's kind of like how do we rebuild
this
and well we need well we already know
how to play a heavy groove
that's their forte
and um
then you have to consider
uh the melody and you know you can
actually play with the melody uh the the
rhythm of the melody you know a lot of
these i mean like the phrasing right
well the phrasing yeah so like um
you know uh
um
you'll hear in a lot of these tunes that
it's clearly the melody but they're
changing the phrasing of it the reason
they're changing the phrasing is because
it went from this kind of groove where
the rhythms or the phrasings yeah
but the but but if they tried to sing it
exactly like say nancy sinatra well it
wouldn't fit
so um what we what we have to decide is
well what do we do great well
you know you know how to play metal bass
you know how to get your sound so you be
you
and then um
well what if we add this and and then
what we would do is we would build the
song
from nothing so
i think for to be successful you have to
boil down
you have to like forget the genre you
have to boil it down to what's just
there and and try to rebuild it now i
don't know if everybody would say that
that would be if i was producing
something and somebody's like we want to
do a cover of this
um
i i take away everything and say forget
what you know but here's the melody
here's the words and and um
and i think the more successful ones are
the more creative ones you know that
will get creative with well i don't know
that you know when i say this lyric
maybe you should do something on the
bass here like higher up or
you know and that's when you well
i mean a prime example of that where the
song changes dramatically as judas
priests diamond and rust right
where um an entire like i think two
verses are dropped out
you know
why exactly i don't i don't i don't know
i mean i've looked up a lot of
background material on that and and i
never really found a satisfactory answer
and that's why
yeah oh that's bold to leave out
the lyric some canonical stuff yeah yeah
yeah
yeah um
but it makes a song work you know in a
way that it becomes it effectively
becomes a new version of the song
you know
i remember hearing it when i was a high
schooler
i had bought judas priest sin after sin
while we were on spring break down in
pensacola not in pensacola in panama
city beach florida i think we're over in
pensacola by buying some supplies and
we're like in a target or a kmart or
something like that there was they'd
always have these bargain racks for
tapes you know we could buy them for
like 99 cents or a buck i always bought
those yeah and i bought um
black sabbaths we sold our soul for rock
and roll which i didn't have at the time
and judas priest sin after sin and you
know i had a boom box and i were out on
the beach and i'm playing it and i was
like wow this is i mean the whole album
is it's one of my favorite priest albums
of all time anyway
um but you know the stuff that we were
listening to at the time was
was a lot heavier
it was uh defenders of the faith
arguably their heaviest album ever and
uh screaming for vengeance which is
pretty close right so so sit after sin
different kind of production different
kind of guitar stuff going on there
and diamonds and rust did not come
across to me as not being a metal song
when i when i heard it and and i didn't
even know the joan baez version i i
thought this was just an original judas
priest composition
this song rocks yeah
me too
and it'd be cool to take a poll to see
how many
you know um priests fans realize it's a
cover
because i didn't well
that yeah that that and uh green
manalishi and better by you better than
me um i mean
they did a couple other covers some of
which were not as successful like johnny
b good which probably belongs in the
cover hall of shame
but i don't think anybody is going to
think that this was an original judas
priest composition whereas better by you
better than me maybe they would um
yeah mark points out so let's actually
talk about this one the green manalishi
right
um
the fleetwood mac version of the green
manalishi is just a hot mess as far as
i'm concerned um you know you listen to
that you listen to judas priest's much
tighter much
heavier
composition in in a way green manalishi
is really only a good song when judas
priest is doing it
the only version of that i know is um
the fleetwood mac uh three cd set from
the boston garden okay and that whole cd
is a mess
i mean it's just like six hour guitar
solos
and um you know i remember somebody
giving it to people hey you know peter
green's got to be your guy and i do love
peter green but
not in this you know in the 70s arenas
so it's like three hours of
self-indulgence
so i agree with you there i think what
yeah um
mark um
i think uh
i think yeah the word is focused they
they yeah
that's a
yeah
now let me ask you this though scott so
a composition like the original green
metal issue that is a mess is that
in a way it leaves more room to improve
upon right
so is it better to do covers of things
that are not already amazing songs like
you know here's an example
motorhead right they've done covers of a
number of things
two that i would focus on here they did
a cover of david bowie's heroes which is
an awesome song
the motorhead version it's good it's
motorhead it's you know you when you
listen to it you can like tell what it
is but it's kind of boring in some
respects because it's just a plotting
baseline
lemmy's not doing anything particularly
interesting with it
um it's you know
guitar riffs that are heavy and
distorted um
but
motorhead's version of louis louis
it's pretty good
you know i don't know if i've heard that
one god that sounds so
like you know
right now without hearing it why
you know
well yeah that's a good question i i
imagine because
first of all lemmy liked it
because it's you know classic rock and
roll you know actually that's a good
point you know what that's you're right
but it but it is a song that because
it's pretty simple and there's not a
hell of a lot going on and it's just
some guys you know making up this is
singing some almost indecipherable
lyrics and it's got a good hook
um there's a lot of there's a lot you
could do to improve it you know oh this
is interesting mark says i've seen an
interview of dio saying he believes
louis louis is a perfect song i would
have to see that because
somebody like dio you know you got to
say what is he thinking
well you know there is
you know there is a thing to that you
know like um i love um
uh love that dirty water boston you're
my home and it's
on on the surf is a stupid song
but
but you listen to it and it's just got
the way the reverb is it sounds like the
times it's uh
it's it's not great
but um there's a uh
there's what we what we call the x
factor the unexplainable you know what
that's well like you know i think
crimson and clover the original you know
so many people have covered crimson and
clover right the original is
like uh one of the more beautiful
you know okay
and just because of the sound it's just
like
um it's perfect i think crimson clover
nobody should have ever covered it
because it's
you can't do that well however that was
you can't improve upon it you mean or i
don't think you can't no because it's
perfect and it's like uh really the the
performance and the way it was recorded
uh was uh completely um
honest it was very honest and it was uh
but it's interesting about like dio
saying that that's a
perfect song and i'm sure he expands
upon that no
it's a perfect song mark has a follow-up
here uh is a perfect song uncoverable or
most coverable and so maybe we have to
talk about
both
but
there's two different kinds of perfect
in that way right
there would be songs that would be
almost
so we're thinking about extremes like
infinitely coverable
because they provide you with
just the right raw material that you
could you could take and provided you're
not you know a mediocre band make into
something of your own
and then um there would be those that
like scott was talking about you can't
actually improve upon the song is
already
as good as it's going to be in its genre
and maybe it can't be transported to
another genre adequately
well it's like a sleepwalk the original
from the 50s uh if anybody knows the
song sleepwalk you've heard it a million
times and it's uh
it's laps it's it's pedal steel and
and everybody's covered that you know
it's been covered to death and i go back
to that 50s recording going
can't beat it now this is just my
opinion though you know and we brought
up stefan wolfe's uh born to be wild um
and magic carpet ride who's gonna have a
magic carpet ride yeah you know there's
there are some decent metal covers of
born to be wild out there like i think
about riot's um version of it which is
probably my my favorite but that's still
nowhere as good as stefanos
right
in my opinion so like i guess mark we're
not answering your i'm not answering
your question um
let's say
i i guess with i'll have my own criteria
i'll offer my own criteria for doing a
metal cover of a song yeah first of all
i have to love whatever the song is in
the first place so that's mine i'm not
saying it's other bands so
you know if if i hear a song a bunch and
let's say greg and i have a project hey
greg i really love this tune
it's just a great tune and i wonder if
you know it would transform to metal so
that'll be the first part of the
processes okay do i love this song
the next thing is
um do i think i could do it justice yeah
yeah you know do i think do i think you
know like i wouldn't touch crimson and
clover i wouldn't get somebody to sing
it i wouldn't
that's not for me i'm not gonna i i
already have the record
this would be you recording it as like
your own thing it's not like you
wouldn't play it at a wedding or
something like that oh no no i'm sorry
you're right uh thanks for clarifying
that it would be me like okay scott we
want you to put two covers on your next
record yeah and they have to be you know
metal versions of
and so
uh then i would be very thoughtful about
the process some of the stuff we've
talked about today um with the the
lyrics uh being enhanced by something
like you said
i love what you said about the jimi
hendrix he's not we're not hearing the
lyrics but we all know what the lyrics
are so we're kind of singing along with
him
and then you know while we hear this
he's given us this vision or he's giving
us this uh audible
kind of uh
movie
and um
so
you know sometimes i go like why this so
i guess you know if deal were to do
louie louie i'd go why but if he said
because i think it's the most perfect
song then i would say okay so you're you
know that's you know okay gotcha you
know
and that's that's a
there's a lot of deal interviews i'm i'm
far behind on i'm sure but is a perfect
song uncoverable
no it it depends if you like it you can
cover it do your own thing with it
yeah you know if it's a perfect song you
know or do you want to mess with it i
hate when people mess with it so
um
like as far as like if they completely
change the harmony you know like
and this is stepping outside of the
metal but um shaka khan um
uh this what was her one of her big
songs um
that david foster produced anyways when
she did it live the musical director
would put all these different reharms in
there and like make it like complicated
and we
should point out too that scott has
played with shakka cut so he's talking
here from experience so go ahead
so um and
my friend jay and i who's uh a session
guitarist in la we're listening we're
like the band's great but
you know what was wrong with the david
foster version i like those chords
better and you know for somebody to kind
of like well i'm gonna make this better
i'm gonna make this more jazzy it
doesn't really work out like i've heard
somebody do todd rugran's can we still
be friends well they changed the harmony
and changed it to something different
and now i don't enjoy i didn't enjoy the
version i didn't enjoy the
you know the treatment of it and they
took the magic chords out the magic
harmony out that gave me kills and so
um
really an art you could do whatever you
want you know i can i can i can uh
put random brushstrokes going this is my
interpretation of uh
degas
and um nobody can tell me i'm wrong but
i guess it's us as
uh listeners do you know uh talking
about you know like what ride like the
wind i thought was fantastic
you know no
we're gonna come back to ride like the
wind but there's there's a song that
comes to mind for me is just
i don't think it can be improved upon um
and that's black sabbath zero the hero
from the era when uh ian gillen is is
the singer just just for that one album
an album that didn't get a lot of um
great response in part because the
production wasn't that good and the
album cover was just terrible that's
born again in 1983
but it is one of the heaviest of metal
songs
and i remember years and years back when
uh somebody who thought they were like
doing me a favor they sent me the
cannibal corpse
um
you know cover of it and i was like this
is i mean i'm not into this kind of this
genre anyway but they did not do justice
to the song as i think about it so
there's actually
um
god flushed at a version black symphony
and sauron did did versions of it and
i'm not i'm probably not going to go
listen to him in in part because
i don't think you can actually
improve upon that song that that's the
song that if i ever get to like walk out
on stage um to you know like a riff or
something i'm taking it from from that
that song um
and so i think there's quite a few like
that it may be impossible you know when
we listen to like tribute albums metal
tribute albums where metal artists are
doing somebody else's stuff i think
there's some motorhead songs that can't
be done
any better than by motorhead or
you know some some iron maiden songs
that i mean there's so many versions of
the trooper out there they are never
going to be as good as the original the
trooper i mean even if you play it on a
harp like that one lady does that's very
cool but it's it's just it's not the
thing uh alfonso says cannibal corpse is
good accountable of course yeah and you
know that's a good way to describe
this this sort of uh jargon about when
we're talking about a band style
taking another
band's work and putting it into their
style yeah judas priest is going to
judas priest right right um
iron maiden when they do
very early in their career uh skyhook's
woman in uniform it's going to be
that that uh sound to it and that was
with paul diana i just watched the video
for that last night actually you did
andy and i both watched it because
when i was playing it she was like
who's that you know and i was like well
that's iron maiden you recognize them
but it's paul diano singing and there's
actually like the whole band is singing
harmonies on it which is a little bit
unusual um
alfonso this is you know
i'm glad you brought this up because
this slipped my mind as greg and i were
putting the notes together
now the first thing that strikes me
weird is let's talk about someone like
ingva
who
in interviews constantly says he has no
influences except for paganini and bach
and and then you know he's been quoted
as saying i owe nothing to richie
blackmore
um and then you know one moment he's
saying hendricks is god the next thing
is like i didn't like his music i just
like that he set his guitar on fire that
made me want to play and so we're taking
talking about somebody that's got
kind of um telling stories right what's
that he's telling stories and in in the
pejorative sense some of these stories
are probably not true
yeah but now here we go now he he did
cover all these and you know rush
this you know kansas
uh you know um
i would
that that that was a shock to me like it
was such a shock that he would say i'm
gonna make pay tribute to some people
and um yeah that's probably the most
shocking if we're going to talk about it
from the other end about the ethos of
the person covering well this is
somebody that would never play a cover
because he's obviously the greatest
thing that's ever happened and you know
and you know richie blackmore was was
okay at the blues stuff he would say you
know but come on he was he dressed like
richie he he had richie blackmore's
moves he played the strat to the
marshall like richie and you know to
take this in in a different uh
direction
and possibly you know open up the
opportunity for a rant on scott's part
one of the things that we've talked
about in the past is people who claim
that they're self-taught right
and
nobody's really self-taught in any real
sense because you're always learning
from somebody if you're even if you're
just like copying stuff off the radio
hey you you were listening to the thing
on the radio right and there's this
notion of like
nobody influenced me it's kind of like
the the claim to be self-taught which
usually goes along with i'm not like all
those phonies over there
it's a badge of honor right
well it's presented as such but is it
really a badge of honor i mean no it's
not you're right it's presented as well
they think it's a badge of honor yeah
why would it be a badge of honor though
i mean why what what's wrong
with um
you know saying uh yeah i learned from
this person this person this person and
then i transformed what they're doing
you'd never get somebody like dio saying
oh i was self-taught man you know
well it's mark cause i'm super original
no i you know a lot of the people that
would
i came up with you know in the clubs and
played
they were the least original players
that said they were self-taught because
i as you know i used to have these
discussions with them that like you know
oh you're studying with charlie benakis
and you know you do all this practicing
i i'm self-taught i go what do you mean
yourself todd i just heard your set you
played a
series of jimmy page licks
and you know i said my argument at the
time was unless you were born in a
bubble and never heard music and was
handed an instrument
yeah i mean you wouldn't know what to
make of it you'd be like what what is
this thing here and now if you created
something on it then you'd be
self-taught but you know
i also asked the question
and i think it's a good question well
you know i i learned from people on
youtube okay so if the people were in
the same room as you
that wouldn't be self-taught but if
they're on a computer screen you're
saying you're self-taught you know like
what is and then when i push people
to say what does self-taught mean
um
and then i i have the other argument
which is
or we are all self-taught right so i
could i i guess what would that possibly
mean though for me that would mean that
would mean i could teach mechanics right
i could teach you scales i could teach
you ways to organize pitches and okay
and all this stuff but well you could
because you actually know that stuff but
right but but let's say i teach you and
they go greg sadler you're not
self-taught because you're studying with
scott truly here's the problem there's a
leap you have to take that i can't take
for you and that is you putting that
together
in music it's like saying we're
for english we're self-taught i didn't
go to school but i could speak english
well
of course we all did go to school
well yeah i know but like you know it's
kind of like that would be a you know
like um
it's kind of a silly comparison so the
self-taught part is
um you can't make anybody a good
musician
you know i can
try to guide you but um you know most of
my students don't sound anything like me
not all of them none of them sound like
me and how is that possible if they're
you know not self-taught well they
they put it together in their own way
and they had to reflect upon it so i
guess i'll finish with this is because
you're right it's a rant but um
i think anybody that's a creative person
right so if you're creative person no
matter how many or how few tools you
have you're going to do great stuff with
it so this thing about you're going to
ruin your creativity by learning well no
because
do you become non-creative when you
learn stuff well and then this goes back
to that thing you know people are
surprised that say blackie lawless would
want to do a uh you know all these
covers of classic 60s and 70s music
because it's not metal right well you
know
being open to learning from other genres
probably makes you
more able to grow as a metal artist if
you're you know if you if you confine
yourself just just to a genre which i
think can be a risk for
some people in the the present
although scott you would know more about
this from the actual musicians side than
i would where people come in and say
i'm you know i'm interested in death
metal and maybe a few other adjacent
genres and that's all i'm going to
listen to you know
these are the only bands that i care
about well you're probably
you know you're narrowing your um
your
area of study
far too much
it's like people too in philosophy who
are like
well so i'm gonna go on a rant myself
you know people in the modern stoic
movement who are like i only read marcus
aurelius epictetus and seneca and maybe
a few other things i'm not going to read
plato you know you can't make me you
know and you're like first of all buddy
nobody's making you you know everybody
gets to develop their own mind but if
you want to
know like what other important
philosophers have taught in the field
i mean it might be a good idea to read
more more widely you know and maybe not
just read philosophy but also read some
history and some literature
you know some other things but you do
get these people who are very very
single minded uh about what they're
going to
yeah so mark points out by looking to
the resources of another tradition you
can better see the weaknesses in your
own oh i agree with that mark and you
can open the ground for musical
innovation yeah
well said i just wanted to respond mark
you said don't they sometimes just mean
that they didn't get formal training
well
what is formal training
training uh does that mean you know you
had a piano teacher come and sit at your
house next to you on a bench is that
formal training
um
you know basically
um
if you're saying you're self-taught but
you're stealing licks from albums and
you're looking at where people put their
fingers on in tutorials on youtube
how is that different than somebody
being in the room doing the same thing
um and here well if you're if you're
formally studying your ears are going to
be far superior because extensive ear
training is involved in you know if you
go to a college say and you know people
lifting stuff by ears but then you get
these people on stage where nobody tells
you what key or what song is going to
happen
somebody with the experience is going to
be able to smoke that you can make 600
bucks you know somebody call me tonight
i won't know a thing about the gig and
i'll do fine because i have ear but
by ear is like you know them you know
rewinding the tape and approximating
what it is and slowing it to half speed
and getting there's nothing wrong with
that i'm not putting it down i'm just
saying there are there is a community of
people that um
that kind of think you're a sellout if
you uh if you've learned something from
somebody and my argument is we've all
learned something from people you know
when i started out you know i didn't
have formal training i just learned
every maiden song and got whatever i
could and then i got more interested in
other things mark like you said
you know i was very narrow-minded um
only to to battle and as i went on it
was kind of um
i agree with exactly what you said it so
well mark that um i heard wes montgomery
i said well what's this this is kind of
cool and and look what you said greg
it's like um
the point i guess the point of
philosophy isn't just to like you know
stick to one school because you know
they they they all kind of interact or
react uh if it's like anything like
music so yeah so so-and-so led to
so-and-so's thinking
and um
i you know you could expand on that
better but like you know having that
narrow mind well people come up onto it
when they're when they're ready
um you know it's kind of like me trying
to tell somebody you know you should
play jazz and you know what i tell them
it's like well you know if you want to
play jazz one day you might you know
come up to it and you might um
you know you might be really interested
in it so
um and that's them exploring it and
being self-taught and going down their
path yeah i think there's a lot of
analogies here between
music and
development and learning and what we
could call academic you know slash
theory stuff rob points out to see what
some thinker artist is responding to you
can better understand it as well which
is perhaps really relevant to the issue
of metal covers and i think that's quite
true yeah rob and you know i i'm going
to say that
so what mark was saying here about
looking to the resources of another
tradition that sounds very familiar to
people who've read aleister mcintyre in
philosophy who talks about how
traditions you know uh draw upon each
other you know a good tradition is one
that has its own integrity but it's also
not just dismissing all the other ones
that's what what keeps traditions
healthy traditions can't be strictly
identified with institutions there's
something more that has to happen there
so i think there's a really rich
conversation that could be
could be had about this drawing
analogies between these two and i'm
going to bring up another wrinkle to
this
in philosophy
one of the
one of the things that i you know
because i get asked a lot of questions
by younger philosophers who are like in
grad school or undergrad or trying to
study on their own
and sometimes they'll have um and i'd be
really interested to hear what rob has
to say about this because he's he's a
philosophy professor as well um
i
get people who are like my professor
tells me i shouldn't read this person
don't waste my time on on this person or
it's going to you know damage me if i'm
reading this and i'm like well screw
your professor who
how do they know what you're actually
supposed to be reading and you think
that reading a book is going to like
break your brain well i mean if that's
really the case then don't don't read
because you're really badly off right
that would be like saying you know if
you if you listen to duran duran you're
not going to be able to
you know play metal anymore you know
but i have that i get students that come
in that way
and they would study with hardcore jazz
people
and and they would come in to me who's
i'm an open book you know and um you
know what are you into i've been
studying jazz for two years well great
you know like what do you
what do you like to listen to well you
know
i really like
you know this metal band and this rock
band but my teacher told me
if i listen to that stuff it's gonna
screw up my time and i'm gonna be
regurgitating bad phrasing
and um i said
why would they say that
and uh well i don't know
and i said so if you stop listening yeah
i stopped listening they said it was bad
for me
and so now but like
when you were saying that my
my eyes lit up because i've had students
say the same things this professor said
don't waste your time on this or this is
not real legitimate whatever yeah
you get people that become kind of like
uh bullies and hindering people's
chance to explore for themselves to find
themselves and yeah i'm sure we you've
probably read plenty of philosophers
going eh
but you read them and you understand it
and you can explain why maybe you don't
uh so so rob says this is true but it
has to be balanced with the finite time
and resources available and i i totally
agree with that so if the if you're
supposed to be reading plato well you
better be reading plato but that doesn't
mean that you can't also read you know
xenophon
and augustine or whoever else provided
you're actually doing what you're
supposed to be doing
and and not just getting infatuated with
with the greener grass right
well i i took what you said to be
different i took what you said to be um
don't
read that philosopher it's garbage well
that's what people do say yeah yeah so
but like you know this rob has a good
point about well you know there's
there's actually not you know if the
teacher were to say why are you reading
this the classes about that and you're
not
you know
um reading aristotle and you should be
yeah that's a good point rob has you
know and you know i'll tell students i'm
like you know listen to what you want
but
whatever we're working on conceptually i
need you to work on that but you know
whatever bonus time you have do whatever
you want with it because that's part of
who you are it's part of how you grew up
it's your influences we're different
generations we're different this you
have your story to tell and um hopefully
you've become good enough musicians we
can all express ourselves
so we are getting a little short on time
and this is a great conversation but i
did want to bring up a few things that
we we have about some of the songs that
we're looking at so i did some digging
and i found uh a discussion by
um
by by biff um byford the you know
ostensibly
not just singer but you know the the
center of saxon
talking about ride like the wind
and uh this is in an interview somebody
said one of the subjects uh touched on
is the band's destiny 1988 album which
is much maligned even by the band and he
says well the thing is it was a bad time
for saxon
i think the content of the album seems
pretty good to me the songs are great
sos and
stuff like that but we were going
through a lot of bad things and the
album really sought and that might have
been kind of a tough time for some of
these bands 1988 anyway and then they
bring up um
there's a great cover of christopher
cross's ride like the wind on there and
then biff byford says yeah it's the best
song on the album actually it's a great
song christopher cross sent us a message
saying he really loved our version we
used to play that christopher cross
album we had a cassette with all the
different songs on
for the bus we used to travel around on
and that song was on the tape so when
the record company said we need a song
that's more like a rock and roll wheels
of steel type thing the producer said
have you got any ideas to recover so i
said yeah ride like the wind might be
good so me and paul transposed it
christopher's version is quite jazzy
but catchy so we developed the catchy
side of it and paul did a great job with
the guitar and chorus into that rock i
mean and here's really interesting it's
a massive song at the time people were a
bit uh ride like the wind you know and
connected it with christopher cross
being a little bit more softer but as
time's gone on the track has become an
absolute massive live favorite so this
is a prime example of a great metal song
that was able to be
transformed from a very different genre
to the satisfaction of the original
artist
i'd be curious
scott what do you think he means he
contrasts jazzy and catchy and he says
we emphasize the catchy side of it what
does that actually
mean
um well the ja jazzy's he's not really
using that correctly um
you know it's a lot of metal artists if
you're using non-traditional chords that
aren't um kind of basic nature and minor
um
um
then the
the generic word is jazzy um but
that riff about that no so like that
that that's a hook and so what what he
means is they kept what really made the
song strong uh like the hooks
and then um you know there's a really
cool part of the song if you think of ry
like the wind
think of
when he goes i've got such a long way to
go and then the drummer goes to halftime
okay
and they kept all that and it was um
i think
i agree with everything he said as far
as i think the guitars did a fantastic
job
um
and um
even when christopher cross plays it
live you know he takes an extended rock
solo at the end of the tune over the da
da da da does he yeah
okay now that part is kind of i guess
that's where they kind of think it's
jazzy
but they did they kept that in there and
um they kept that hook there but i said
because i thought to myself when we get
to that
part of the cover i wonder if they're
going to skip it
because that would be what they would
see is jazzy but they didn't say yeah
they actually did a great job and i my
favorite part of that is that
christopher cross
you know reached out to them and said he
that warms my heart that's just yeah
that's like with the judas priest joan
baez saying hey my kid loves your cover
thanks for doing it because i'm cool now
right now we can contrast this with
twisted sisters leader of the pack which
is is you know it's uh it is a metal
tune
um there have been some interesting
interviews from former members you know
twisted sister is broken up jj french
says i regret that leader of the pack
should not have been the lead single
from the love for suckers album i don't
think there was a mistake in recording
it and now this is really interesting we
used to play it in the bars so we knew
it worked for the bars
i think the emphasis on the song as a
single was a mistake and helped usher in
the end of the band mark mendoza the
bassist who was interviewed said when we
came when we made come out and play i
believed it was wrong i didn't believe
we should do a theme album people did
like it but i just wanted to do hard
rock heavy metal songs and a few anthems
in your face metal there was no reason
to try to make a masterpiece at this
point give people what they expected of
us that's all
and then he said um
a song like leader of the pack did not
belong there we did it as a spoof and a
novelty thing in the club so this is
ethos stuff
but it shouldn't have been on the album
and then um
you know he says uh you know it was it
was a massive song for
the clubs because people really liked it
and he said i was the only one who
didn't want to do it back then we took a
vote and out of the five guys i was the
only one who didn't raise my hand the
record company management the rest of
band believed this was the right way to
go
for us and so
you know it's it's it's i would say it's
not a great cover myself i don't know
what do you think about it scott i
remember getter
no i remember being on the radio every
hour you know on the rock station and i
remember being so disappointed um
but now i you know it
yeah absolute spoof um you know another
spoof not to get off the subject we
forgot about typo negative doing summer
breeze
so that's no metal lyrics at all and i
think that was pete steele trying to be
funny
yeah i don't know if anybody here has
heard that um typo negative did a cover
of uh summer breeze uh well that would
be this sort of what we call ironic
right or ironic right yeah
yeah and um
i think he you know i saw typo in
negative
a few times and you know they take he
takes shots at himself you know
and you know i remember one show he he's
like um
uh oh you think i'm a jerk huh well you
paid five dollars to get in here five
american dollars and we're getting paid
so who's a jerk you know but like you
know the five dollar thing was just kind
of like you know we paid more than that
but yeah yeah he's kind of like putting
himself down that like that's all
they're worth and then he would throw
like toilet paper out and he want you to
toilet paper the room so they were kind
of um they were great but they were uh
kind of a comedy act yeah
so as far as the ethos
and we are going to do a um session just
on parody metal later on down the line
with of course you know um spinal tap
and steel panther featuring heavily
oh yeah we should we should take mark's
comment and then we should probably wrap
this up think about something like
anthrax's cover of public enemies bring
to noise
bringing together two genres not usually
associated an arguably an important step
to new metal
which love it or hate it was
commercially massive particularly in the
90s and early 2000s yeah
so
when when we're talking about fusing
things together like that
it is a cover
um
and it's transforming i mean anthrax
i i'd be curious to see what you think
about this guy i mean they start out
as a
a band that is doing more straight ahead
you know
competent speed metal slash thrash and
then they start spiraling off into all
these other
things but they did have a back history
through sod of doing a lot of kind of
goofy stuff
uh anthrax yeah
i mean
i'm sorry so what's the question
um i guess the the point is bringing
together these two genres oh right
um
yeah i was trying to find the right word
i think um
the thing i loved about this
uh and this actually uh well
let me finish my thought i gotta keep
getting better at this
i tend to like go off on to the next
side so um
i thought socially this was really cool
because anthrax was doing something that
the fans may have hated but
the fans
loved anthrax and said well if anthrax
thinks they're cool
then maybe we're going to check this out
and it's kind of a point yeah and that's
kind of what we saw with aerosmith and
run dmc remember when they did walk this
way because it was you know um daryl uh
from run dmc said you know we
everybody in the neighborhood used to
try to wrap that you weren't cool if you
couldn't do walk this way so that
brought like you know the new emergence
of like this hip hop
or rap and classic rock and then all of
a sudden
everybody in the school was buying run
dmc and you know the the kids that were
listening to run dmc were like checking
out aerosmith and i think yeah yeah
these are kind of uh mark this is
another great point um i think socially
this is really great and then um what it
does is it does fuse the genres
and it breaks down walls into you know
sometimes as fans you know people like i
only like this kind of metal i don't
like this metal i don't like this and
i'll never listen to the country and
i'll never but you know um what if uh
you know black sabbath did something i
don't know maybe they'd be
you know like somebody iconic does
something
uh crossover and the fans go oh well
because they did it maybe i'll be open
to
um and i thought it was kind of cool
you know yeah i think that that's a
that's a good point bands have
um
once they're they reach a certain
stature they have a certain influence
that they can
exploit to move music now you could also
if you go too far you can really screw
things up you could think about um
some bands that have like
well you know um
[Music]
who is it that was doing the dancing
around
um and and base in in the video and
basically like uh ruining it
you're not talking about bowie and uh
jagger
no no no i mean they could get away with
whatever they wanted basically that was
a close call though we were all pretty
disappointed
when they did dancing in the street and
the video was awful
yeah that's not coming to me but this is
this is probably a good place to uh
close things out millie vanilli yeah
that was a whole different thing they
got caught lip syncing uh which i guess
is a big no-no especially if it's a live
performance
and at the time
you know it's widely used now but at the
time
it was really you know the cd skipped
right that's how they were caught right
right yeah yeah and then yeah so and
god and kelly clarkson no not kelly
clarkson who's the one that got caught
on snl
i i know what you're talking about um
wasn't she like the younger sister of
somebody else ashley simpson
yeah yeah thanks rob
and and you know that was just
it's sort of like a actually this is
another topic that that scott was
pitching to me um yesterday the sort of
agreement between the bands and the the
fans you know what what are the
unwritten rules governing this and i
think we're going to do a whole session
on this next time lip syncing seems to
be a violation of that it certainly is
for metal you know i mean if you have a
metal band that gets up there and
suddenly the track skips
that's
that's a big problem for that well molly
crew is playing to mostly tracks the
last
the last tour oh really
yeah because you know they
so it was mostly tracks and
people were calling them out that were
at soundcheck and then it went viral you
know kind of viral and then um or when
they use
um
fake
harmony vocals
that's a big no-no because you know
do you know do it the way it does have
to be just like the record i mean
to me that's a disappointment yeah and
this is really an issue for older bands
where you know musical pipes are wearing
out and maybe the fingers can't play as
fast or you know that's part of the
experience that i pay for yeah you know
i mean i guess people say you have to
put on a good show put on your best show
or don't go out
that's something that that d snyder has
made a case for a number of times he he
actually so we're you know we did a
thing about this a long time ago what
what do bands owe their fans in terms of
farewell tours and d snyder has been
he's made you know quite extensive
ethical arguments about this saying if
you can't perform up to the level that
you you know you should be doing you
don't have any business being out there
on stage that's why i'm not doing
twisted sister anymore just widowmaker
because i can't jump around safely like
i used to you know
uh
and the answer of using backing tracks
is is unacceptable
yeah
mark has a great line here retire a hero
or perform long enough to see yourself
become the villain
oh it's great
you know and that's true because that's
you know we were discussing and just to
touch into it that's where as a fan you
feel slighted and you get angry right
yeah so it's like you you paid your 200
through ticketmaster and you go and you
find out the band's playing to tracks
and um what a slap in the face for
somebody that's bought your
vinyl records and your posters and
looked up to you for three decades what
a way to treat somebody like that you
know yeah
like you know
you'll have more to see on that i think
you'll have some great insight but um
you know i know as a fan that these
things would make me angry like you know
you spend time buying these people's
albums i remember meeting jack blades
and he couldn't have been more rude to
me
and um and i got really upset and i
shouldn't have taken it personally but i
took it personally because
i was there from the first record with
them you know and i need tickets to see
their shows and you know all you had to
do is you know i i didn't want anything
from him i just introduced him
introduced myself and said it's really a
pleasure to meet you and he goes yeah uh
are you part of the meet and greet
and i said was that happening he goes no
you missed it
and so he didn't want to talk to me he
didn't want to even say hi to me
um yeah
and i just thought that was you know wow
okay so you know i've been a fan for all
this time and this is what i get it's a
lack of acknowledgement
you know
and it shows it shows ingratitude that's
something we could
magnanimous that i think was mark that
brought the word magnanimous up right in
that yeah episode a few times ago
thanks mark because greg greg and i
discussed that later and uh
i've been keeping that kind of to myself
to think about um the position you're in
then how you should act you know you're
out to a different standard and should
be held to a different standard
that's true rock stars
maybe there's a instead of being you
know all about privilege it should also
be about commitment and
responsibility you know so but that's
that's a topic for another day so
thanks everybody for
um all the great you know comments
suggestions uh i enjoyed this
conversation i'm i'm sure scott did i
really did well yeah
so um this is our first like
re-approaching a topic but we may do
this again in the future and uh
we'll see all of you uh next time around
scott you want to take us out do you
have any last things you want to say or
well actually i just want to say uh
everybody thank you so much for joining
in
it's always insightful always uh
gives me something to either rant about
or
think about or think about but you know
i like how how we we start with
something we cover it and then um you
bring up interesting stuff and uh
i end up getting more out of the
conversation because you're here
um you know
uh
greg and i'll talk for 10 hours straight
about metal i think you know but it's
great to have some other people here
some other perspectives yeah it's very
good
you